we've been talking about the projection
that we hear from the write about
political violence we're going to speak
to David Newark on today's program about
this issue of right-wing violence among
other things but despite the rights
claim that most political violence is on
the left the reality is that most
political violence in the United States
comes from the right against the left in
case in point yesterday George Soros the
billionaire philanthropist and sort of
like favorite punching bag target of the
right responsible for absolute and utter
evil if you ask them behind every
conspiracy theory almost that they come
up with an explosive device was found in
his mailbox it wasn't just something
that looked like an explosive it was
actually an explosive device that was
proactively detonated by a bomb squad
that was called police responded
yesterday at 3:45 to his house an
employee had opened the mailbox saw what
looked like an explosive device
Soros wasn't even home and this guy is
sort of the darling target anti-semites
target George Soros because he's Jewish
anti liberals target George Soros
because he uses his money to push
leftist causes anti anyone who backed
Obama types attack George Soros because
he's a rich guy who backed Obama and
extremists who use the threat of
violence based on political beliefs we
typically call that terrorism right but
typically you see hesitation to apply
that term to incidents like this and if
you look at some of the enclaves on the
Internet where this issue is being being
discussed they are celebrating it in all
of the usual places on the internet and
then they are also moving to false flag
conspiracies George Soros had the device
planted himself in order to make the
right look bad which is of course so
stupid because you don't need false
flags to make it seem as though the
right are the purveyors of the
overwhelming majority of political
violence in the United States
anecdotally we've recently talked about
Heather hare who was run over and killed
at that
right white supremacists March in
Charlottesville we've talked about
numerous mass shootings with assault
rifles by individuals motivated by
right-wing ideology we've talked about
the cheering of body-slamming reporters
by Republicans when they ask questions
you don't like that was the President of
the United States
cheerleading that by the way we've seen
indifference to the killing of
journalist Jamal khashoggi but when the
left
interrupts Stephen Miller's sushi night
or Sarah Huckabee Sanders chicken meal
at the red hen in West Virginia or
Virginia wherever it was that's uncivil
Pat and that's over the line and if you
kneel during the national anthem it's
also disrespectful tucker carlson can't
go to restaurants anymore the right has
almost a near monopoly on actual
political violence and it's really
important number one don't be sucked
into this false debate about where is it
okay to protest is it okay to protest at
sushi restaurants or can you only
protest political people doing horrible
things at Indian restaurant don't fall
for that false debate and don't fall for
the projection that the political
violence comes from the left I saw an
ant Aoife video of somebody throwing a
bike lock okay well left-wing terrorism
was more prevalent in the 1960s you had
eco-terrorism you had some animal rights
extremism mostly property damage
generally didn't target people but we've
had now more than 30 years of
predominantly right-wing violence
against actual people go back to the
1984 murder of Alan Berg the liberal
radio host look at domestic extremists
murders in the United States
seventy-four percent are done by
right-wingers that doesn't even conclude
those by ultra conservative Islamic
extremists I argue it should any kind of
violence motivated by religious
fundamentalism of that kind whether it's
Muslim or Christian or Jew or whoever it
is right-wing by its very nature
we're not even including that Pat and 74
percent of political murders in the US
are done by the right yeah
we'll say that liberals are doing a poor
job it's showing that violence on the
right is much more prominent than
violence by the left and maybe that has
to do with the fact that Republicans are
in power now so there's a lot of other
things to go after like liberals will
criticize say like the travel ban okay
or family separations or Trump trying to
gut the Affordable Care Act so there's a
lot of content there there's a lot of
more tangible things that liberals can
go after I agree that that's true but
it's not like the left was successful at
making it very clear that the majority
of the political violence was on on the
right when Barack Obama was president so
I don't know that that's fully
responsible for it but still the right
will continue to say no matter who's
president that it's liberals and
Democrats who do the violence and and of
course they have no data to back that up
whatsoever the reason it matters is that
you can't solve the problem if you allow
them to miss state reality and if you
slice it any way that you want the
reality is that the overwhelming
majority of political violence
extremists domestic political violence
is coming from the right sometimes
against moderates who aren't right
enough but overwhelmingly against people
on the left and we are going to continue
talking about it today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blink Asst it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the
all access to thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k ma n